the agent said well i have good news and
bad news
so the good news is that the project
that you
discussed with her
gary you're a former attorney turned
hollywood producer criminal defense
attorney correct correct okay
i'm sure you've seen some good sides of
people and maybe some not so good sides
from what you've seen how true is it
that screenplays are stolen that ideas
are stolen
or ideas really can't be stolen
well i i wouldn't go so far society as
cannot be stolen but in my experience
it's extraordinarily rare
i see a lot of writers very concerned
about it and my my advice to them is by
all means protect your work your ip
needs to be protected you've worked hard
so at a minimum you want to put a
copyright notice on it but you also want
to register it for copyright which are
different right
and for extra
an extra layer of frosting on the cake
you might want to register it with the
writer's guild of america
after that i wouldn't worry about it
um
i've i personally never the kinds of
things that i'm concerned about are not
theft of intellectual property
uh so much as unfair dealings
right it's a totally different beast
um but but actual theft of whether it's
an idea or a
an existing screenplay or teleplay
um i've never personally actually had
that experience i've been in the
business a lot of years
i know it happens only because i read
about it once a decade in the in in a
trade paper that someone so claims x
happened
um
but i wouldn't be concerned about it my
attitude was always when i was managing
a young writer
i want the world to read this so i'm
willing to i'll make a million copies
i'll hire a helicopter and drop it out
over the city of la and let everybody
read this beautiful script
because i don't believe they're going to
steal it
um
so i think there's a difference between
protecting your work and worrying about
it
and um
you know on on
the only thing i would add on the flip
side of that is don't be too casual
about where you invest your time
and thus your
where you
uh how you disseminate your script
so while i was joking about the
helicopter i'm joking it's you know
you really want to choose wisely how you
use your time who you invest your time
in meeting
um
and if you do that well
then the other becomes sort of a
non-item
you know if you're if you're careful
about who you are building as your
you know your professional
infrastructure
then i wouldn't give a second thought to
it um i think it's it's very hard to
steal and get away with stealing
intellectual property it's a very
close-knit business
and if it were to happen there are
protections
but you can't stop it so why worry about
something you can't
stop
well from reading the comments of some
of our videos you know people have taken
a lot of
detail and and just time to recount
their stories or a story of a friend of
theirs where a lot of it sounds very
similar where they go into pitch
somewhere and then a very similar idea
comes out usually with names changed but
sometimes people said that stuff hadn't
really been totally changed so i i tend
to think
most of those stories were true but i
have no way to personally
verify that
i'm sure that is actually more common
than the theft of existing scripts
i
i also think people
need to realize that ideas
i don't know that ideas were ever all
that tremendously valuable but in
today's world less so
and i would suggest
i i would advise people not to be so
excited about their idea that they're
busy pitching as an idea all the time to
everyone they encounter
it's actually
a bad practice if you have an idea
that's that's so exciting to you then
put on the breaks and write it
and then you can protect it
but ideas that you know if you're
constantly saying oh i have this
wonderful idea let me tell you about my
idea
don't be surprised if somehow some
version of that seeps into someone's
consciousness intentionally with
with malice or not
and finds
a life
somewhere else
you've invited that
um you know i think you have your inner
circle that you know and you trust and
you can bounce ideas with them that's
fine that's different but i'm talking
about people who are
i got an email from
[Music]
someone
two days ago
who had been at a meeting with these two
gals in malibu this young guy was at a
meeting with these two gals and he
pitched them this idea he's written he's
never written a screenplay but he's
written a couple of books apparently i
don't know the details
and they said oh well maybe gary
and i get an email saying i have this
wonderful idea you know
and i wrote him back and said i really
am not sure what you're asking me
from what you're saying it sounds like
there is no script
and he wrote back he said no it's but i
thought maybe if i wrote a treatment you
read i was like oh my gosh
um you know
i i really would would encourage you
you're a natural writer apparently
you've published books
write the screenplay
um
because this idea of disseminating ideas
and and and treatments
no one can grab hold of that there's no
real concrete outcome of great value
that you might anticipate coming from
that
so why do it
so
don't worry about pitching ideas if you
really feel
so connected to something actually spend
time with the screenplay
get it registered get it copyrighted and
then go from there
don't ask for permission and
tiptoe around don't wait for the
universe to bless you unless there's a
specific outcome
where it makes sense and that happens
all the time i might want to pitch an
idea
uh in the confines of uh you know a
close relationship that i might have
with let's say another producer or with
a writer so here's the i want to develop
you know here's an idea
um
does this excite you is this something
you'd be interested in working on with
me
that's one context
and it makes perfect sense because it
has to be birthed we all birth stories
out of thin air there's nothing and then
there's a story and then there's a
screenplay so along that trajectory
there are times when we want to find
people that we want to draw into the
process
but to pitch it just to let people know
that we're excited about something and
we're working on something
um
you know again if it's if it's someone
you know and trusts fine but
i wouldn't make a habit of pitching
ideas
and i won't even use the word pitch
because that presumes something it's
a you know term of art but
i wouldn't necessarily be
sharing
hither and yan an idea that you really
do are serious you have serious
intention that you're gonna actually
craft that into a project and do a
screenplay or tell a play
i would i would be a little bit i'd
at least at a minimum you should create
a treatment and copyright it and you
know if you want to batten down the
hatches and be pitching the idea that's
okay but really document it
protect it
and now you have a basis for
a claim should that rare occurrence
happen which is that someone actually
steals your idea
gary you mentioned you were more worried
about unfair
dealings what does that mean well not
everybody's well behaved uh
hollywood's no exception um
i you know so there are we all say we
have war stories right and and certainly
there have been
all right i'll give you an example
um
i will try not to dance around it so
it's there are many versions of it
here's one version one version is
uh an agent calls me and says i have a
hip pocket client
would you meet with her absolutely i'm
delighted to meet with her
i asked for a little bio biographical
material maybe anything she's written
whether it's a screenplay or not just
so i i welcome her she comes for a
meeting
and she's absolutely fascinating really
funny and bright it's hysterical her
family is remarkable and she um
i won't get into because maybe it's
identifiable but anyway there's
something very unique going on it's but
the family is eccentric and brilliant
and
um
so she she's just
i always ask a lot of questions so she's
filling me in on this whole family
history and her personal journey after
college and this and that and the other
thing and i see this is all great okay
great so an hour into it i said would
you mind
terribly if i pitch you a story
and she's like
okay
and all i did was i took everything she
had just told me
which she would never have conceived of
as a story worthy of the big screen
and i pitched her a comedy because it
was
like an intelligent comedy like
brilliant
and i pitched it back to her as a
feature idea and you could see her eyes
getting saucer wide very excited like oh
my god that's my family's story that's
me
and she said i love it i said okay so
here's the thing you said you're going
back home for a visit
so uh i would love to ask not as a
homework assignment but just you know if
you would
gather up the local newspaper publisher
gather up a bunch of the editorials
copies of the paper bring back your
yearbooks from school bring back these
abcdefg
and let's dig into this this could be a
lot of fun
and she was all excited like this is
amazing yes i want to do this this is
great i said thank you for coming by
she i said
call me you know just be in touch when
you're back she said i'll be gone three
weeks
so four weeks go by
five weeks go by
and i think you know i'm gonna call her
agent
and i called her agent i said um
you know so-and-so was so lovely and we
i did i know we talked about it and it
was such a great meeting and she was
going to be gone three weeks and she
said she'd be in touch when she got back
and i haven't heard from her i just want
to make sure is everything okay
and the agent said well i have good news
and bad news
so the good news is that the project
that you
discussed with her
is now set up and i said let me guess
that the bad news
i'm not involved
and she said yeah
and she gave me a reason the reason
in that instance was
well i took it to a senior vice
president and she has some people with
deals and she needed to feed a project
to one of their people that are under
contract and us no
that's lovely of you to try and find a
reason to make me feel better but it
doesn't because i know the only reason
i'm not involved is because you didn't
want me involved had you said there was
a producer on it it never would have
occurred to an executive to think
otherwise
so there look these things happen and
over the course of several decades
you're going to have a multiple of these
stories
lost opportunities
uh
people who be
just
exercise poor judgment
omit information
amid information um act what they think
may be in their self-interest that may
or may not be true
um you know i've i've
i've set up projects in studios on a
handshake with the under verbal
understanding with an agent
different from the story i just told
that they wouldn't close the
you know they wouldn't paper the
underlying rights to the script
on behalf of their writer client until
my producing deal was at least codified
as an email informally right
and i've had that violated
now you think to yourself
how would a person do that
because they were going to get a
commission
on my fee
right a single project commission
well it makes no sense that they would
chop my knees off
because it's going to cut my fee in half
but they do it
and i'm not it's like i still got a
movie made i've still made a great fee
right
uh was i happy about it no
but
you know you can't here's the thing
i trust people
and i would much rather go through life
like very very occasionally being
disappointed
rather than going through life
mistrusting people and saying you got a
sign you know everything has to be
buttoned down
i expect you're going to behave badly no
because the truth is that
i can tell you stories but
they're
they're they're they're a needle in the
haystack of my experience over the
course of my years in the business
most people behave reasonably well and
it's on us i do think it's incumbent on
us to be really clear
and state aloud
what we care about
and what we expect and
if we're uncomfortable then just do a
one-page memo
i mean there is a lesson i'm too
trusting i know that
um but there's a way not to have that be
your experience on a consistent basis
it's
you know if you stay in any business
long enough you're gonna have a couple
of disappointments but they're not
life-altering
one hopes
you